after making a splash at the sony press
conference here at e3 2015 I've got the
guys from treyarch on the couch to talk
about call of duty black ops 3 joining
me Jason blundell and david vonderhaar
for treyarch guys III black ops 3 you
got big smiles on your faces you feeling
good it's fantastic it's a it's great
kind of getting on the stage with Vaughn
being on the stage and showing and and
kind of revealing black ops 3 to the to
the public's but just showing it why
getting people to get a glimpse of that
four player co-op campaign switching
between and we'll take a look at that in
a minute but uh yeah bond you were up on
stage yourself man look this is a really
big day for us 12-year history of the
franchise Call of Duty multiplayer has
never been playable on the show floor so
there's the first time for everything
and feels good to be a part of that the
booth looks great there's a great set up
over there a lot of stations a lot of
hands-on time feels good to get the game
out in the hands of people you're going
to be looking over some shoulders later
on today I have a we have a special
arrangement where we can see out over
the over into the thing from up top it's
a little bit like The Truman Show we can
kind of like overlords we can look on to
the space you know you cannot assert all
giving your I you know your world view
here in black ops 3 guys it's a dog
twisted future you know it is a dark
twisted future and we're jumping right
into it here sort of showing us the
waiting for team set up yeah this what
to talk about the the four player
campaign yeah cooperative play
throughout its yeah it's fantastic so
this is a return to kind of coop for
campaign the last time we did it was
with world at war and and this one we
can decide from loot from the ground up
considering about kind of co-op and it
was like okay well as soon you start
thinking about four players going to
going through that space you start
thinking about larger spaces and she's
nothing about larger spaces then we had
to kind of fundamentally like reconsider
our AI system so the AI is absolutely
brand-new is a brand new system because
he has to deal with those multiple
players be able to move around there and
then a brand new animation set on top of
that so all the animations are brand new
and then as we did that right well well
we're in there okay different archetypes
new archives so rather than just kind of
this standard like is the kind of grunt
guy we've got like you know different
kind of guys there who have different
strategy
yeah bipedal robots now for the first
time and they have a different strategy
they don't have to worry about
self-preservation so they're not hiding
behind the cover popping up and shooting
they'll walk forward they'll actually go
into formation so the AI can actually
communicate together so go into phalanx
kind of formations or if one's charging
kind of link up and connect together you
know a robot can say I want to charge in
a column because even you kill the first
one the second one will get second one
will keep marching show so brand new AI
system the coop and then we come up is
then about personalization so you know
something that MPs been very strong for
MP all this time we can now gain to carb
as well so into the campaign which is
customizing your weapons a cyber cause
these new abilities that you can have
see can have been activated in the in
the clip as well changing the characters
look even now the sex of the codes as
well be a male or female and as you go
through the campaign you get more
options to kind of customize it so you
can have your own personality and decide
kind of what kind of soldier you want to
be never short on ambition you Trey our
guys is worth doing do right you know
absolutely yeah and the kit I think the
customization really comes into play all
the more because you have four players
out there on the field you don't want
everyone having the same guns and the
same abilities because the nature of
co-op play is you get that diversity of
experience you get that sort of
different people stepping into different
roles adapting as the battlefield
develops and we've seen as the player
right so you know we got guys on the
team you like you know I'm a Russia so
they they get the shotgun they pimped
the shotgun out they then equip cyber
Corps abilities that are very much about
kind of proximity in close proximity
with guys then we have other guys who
kind of hang back you know in the MP
world that we can pose and that's a bad
thing wit campaign its support right so
they can move back in and shoot guys in
the field is you seeing like a new video
at the moment this is one of our kind of
more open areas so rather than the
follow guy it's his this space is this
objective move around in whatever way
you want to solve the problem right and
it's we've got these quad tanks and his
reinforcements being brought in as well
and you know he's doing the wall runs
there these are all upgrades that you
can purchase so I may take that option I
might think that my strategy is a death
from above strategy and hits wall
running and double jumping another
technique so I'll key to my strategy
well another guy might say no no my
strategy is more like detonation and
setting traps and doing other things so
so von when you come into a situation
like this you're playing a little
campaign co-op help
not the guys on the campaign side do you
find yourself channeling some
multiplayer tactics or is it a whole
different situation now look it for me
it's a different situation but it really
depends on the group that you're playing
with so what what I love about it on a
very personal level is you would set up
and play any one of these levels it like
you would from a multiplayer point of
view which is to say hey if you take
this and I take this will be most
effective and what's kind of fun is when
you go back and play it again you're
trying to figure out the best
combination of stuff to put together on
your squad to be successful like we
weren't so good with that and you know
if we had done this instead so let's
change our equipment or load out and
take these abilities cyber Corps
abilities instead or these guns instead
and that's very got a kind of a sandbox
vibe to it that's very prominent in
multiplayer yeah it's kind of injecting
its way into this and I feel like you
know that's great because you're putting
the universe of multi player and a
traditional what would be a traditional
campaign experience and putting those
together bring them a little closer
makes the game more connected and you
know I think all of us attract have been
trying to find a way to do that and I
think it's like because once in a game
that only kind of play through singer
play and go through but then also come
back with your friends you know maybe
you progress further but your friends a
little bit early you want to get to come
back there and and still be having a fun
time you know and so there's different
spaces to explore different areas where
you might not seen it the first time so
that's why you take those systems and
they say I so you can allow different
and new experiences each time you kind
of come back and play really interesting
to see the way that you know the sort of
campaign and multiplayer areas of design
sort of feed off each other and get you
know get intermingled in terms of the
under the core philosophy here with call
of duty I mean it's one of the things
that the three-year development cycle
gave us was the ability to spend that
first year trying to figure how much we
get to mingle together it makes me so
happy we talked about this earlier which
is seeing narrative elements now
entering into multiplayer seeing kind of
characters with personality and so forth
you know I live and breathe for telling
stories on the narrative and then
obviously the fun and as we've now got
cop in there as well it's like taking
more from the MPN and I love the fact
that I'm now seeing personality kind of
coming into the MP game
Jason's referring to the specialist the
nine playable characters in mp and they
do they have back stories and you know
there's a secret way in the campaign
game that their reference right because
it's a big universe so you don't you
don't see him to verbatim and keep the
universe big you you connect them to the
world and they're part of the timeline
sort of them directly and it's a little
bit of a secret Hal but it's fun and
there's a one if there's one thing we
know about Trey are could tell you guys
love your Laird stories you're inter
connection yeah you're right you know
zombie trickery and all that stuff I
talked about they're not going to use
that word we'll look forward to hearing
that word maybe a little later this year
as we look towards the fall release of
call of duty you guys have set a date
right yes yeah that's right so
playstation 4 xbox one and pc and we're
on november six fantastic david
vonderhaar Jason blundell thank you guys
so much for coming on kicking off our
stage show here with call of duty black
ops 3